Daniela Monet is the latest former child
actor to call out Nickelodeon
I knew something was off some of the
Wardrobe on the show was not age
appropriate and that she quote wouldn't
even wear some of that today as an adult
former Zoe 101 actress Alexa Nicholas is
the latest child star to criticize
Nickelodeon over its traumatic and
unsafe environment I did not feel
protected at Nickelodeon as a child
personally and so I'm demanding that
Nickelodeon starts protecting children
he said he wasn't getting royalties
anymore which is really interesting
Jason Nash's podcast and Jason is still
getting royalties from Drake and Josh
yeah but Josh wasn't because he was a
kid when he was doing it screwed and
sold us out in uh negotiations with
Nickelodeon because they were kind of
Ruthless and um they didn't pay their
leads uh residuals I see the problem oh
do you if you want to make a lot of
money with a TV network there's only one
demographic you gotta focus on children
that's because it's not just the child
viewers that make his TV so lucrative
it's also the child actors child actors
are naive and easy to manipulate they
don't know what's appropriate or normal
yet they are in any position to
negotiate a higher pay and they
definitely don't want to do anything
that will blow their shot at being
famous child actors will do whatever it
takes to succeed on screen wink wink and
their parents are just as desperate and
Nickelodeon has taken full advantage of
this
all of our favorite shows growing up
have some very disturbing stuff going on
behind the scenes child actors ripped
off for Millions abusing child actors
abusing child actors in a way that would
definitely get this video to monetize if
we went into it and it's only now that
these child actors are all grown up that
these disturbing Revelations are coming
to lights stay dangerous subscribe for
more and this is the Dark Side of
Nickelodeon
[Music]
foreign
even the largest corporations like
Nickelodeon have humble beginnings and
with the right plan a small business can
become an Empire like them as well and
speaking of planning many businesses
today are unprepared for the holiday
orders coming up which can lead to
headaches and a lot of one star reviews
so if you own a business that ships
orders then spending the next 60 seconds
to learn about our sponsorship station
is going to save you a ton of time
Goodwill and money ship station makes
shipping stuff easier than ever by
letting you automate all of your manual
work while also hooking you up with the
best shipping rates out there like up to
84 off from Top carriers like UPS USPS
and DHL Express that's why over 130 000
companies use shipstation including Joe
Rogan's brand Onyx with a free trial and
a simple setup process you can start
shipping easier in less than five
minutes start by creating an account
then you connect your online seller
accounts like Shopify Amazon Etsy and
eBay most platforms are supported and
finally you connect your shipping
carrier account or choose a new carrier
and that's it you're ready to start
getting all the benefits of shipstation
including shipping automation instant
tracking updates and a carrier
comparison tool so save money on
shipping this upcoming holiday season by
going to shipstation to get a 60-day
free trial that shipstation.com for a
free 60-day trial with the link below
thanks to shipstation for sponsoring
this video
Nickelodeon wasn't always the wacky
borderline inappropriate billion dollar
conglomerate it is today it started out
as a simple idea to create a TV network
just for kids you see before Nickelodeon
and all the other kiss channels that
were established throughout the 80s kids
TV shows ran periodically on adult
channels children had to wake up bright
and early on a Saturday morning just so
they could watch their favorite cartoon
for an hour kids wanted more television
but it just wasn't available for them so
it was a huge untapped markets so in
1977 a woman named Dr Vivian Horner
launched the first official Nickelodeon
TV show before the channel was even
established to confirm that there was
indeed a market for Less the show
pinwheel aired on a local channel only
in Columbus Ohio and it took off
immediately kids just couldn't get
enough Nickelodeon knew that they needed
to add more shows to keep children
watching around the clock and after just
two years the Nationwide Nickelodeon
channel was born Nickelodeon
revolutionized cable TV all of a sudden
kisko watch shows every single day from
8 AM to 11 pm no boring inappropriate
adult shows and no TV ads either just
entertaining kid-friendly contents and
it was great for adults too because the
channels kept their kids locked in
without a peak for hours on end but even
though kids from all over had their eyes
glued to the screen Nickelodeon wasn't
making as much money as you would think
back then in fact at the time the
channel was about 40 million dollars in
depth and soon children were getting
bored of the same repetitive shows and
the channel was starting to drown that's
when the vice president of Nickelodeon
Geraldine laburn made a decision to save
the brand she started to run
advertisements on the channel
advertising to adults on TV was
completely normal but using television
to Target kids that was a little bit
more unorthodox but it worked kids were
begging their parents to spend all their
birthday and Christmas money on
Nickelodeon products the advertising
decision also came with a full Rebrand
the logo was changed to the orange spot
that we all came to know and love and
later a flashy new production called the
kiss Choice Award was created the Kids
Choice Awards show allowed kids to cast
their vote for their favorite shows
music and movies for the first time ever
they also created a sister Channel
called Nick Jr to start capturing even
younger kids into the Nickelodeon
Universe the channel was trying anything
to get every single kid out there hooked
on Nickelodeon and it was working better
than they could have ever dreamed of the
network was blowing up and the Golden
Age of Nickelodeon was fast approaching
and with that everything was about to
change
[Music]
foreign
became an iconic brand
[Music]
they started releasing classic cartoons
like Rugrats Doug and Ren and Stimpy
then came Rocco's Modern Life cat dog
Hey Arnold and the Wild Thornberries
Nickelodeon shows were becoming so
popular that they could literally use
their cartoons as spokespeople for kids
advertisements
today
[Music]
it's new Nickelodeon bailouts round
Snoopy dog and more Nickelodeon
characters now on Fruit Roll-Ups what
fun Fruit Roll-Ups where we roll out
with next
SUNY scored a deal with Sony Wonder to
release compilations of their episodes
as VHS tapes Nickelodeon Productions
were getting as big as blockbuster
movies and the kids were obsessed
sweepstakes by the mid 90s Nickelodeon
was the number one cable channel by
daily viewers and at that time their
biggest cartoon Cash Cow hadn't even
been released yet peaches
SpongeBob SquarePants yes of course he
lives in a pineapple you silly
hello I like money it was right in the
middle of all this success that
Nickelodeon started branching out from
cartoons to create more shows with real
live child actors they gave a few
different shows a shot but one of them
stood out well Above the Rest all that
stop look and watch ready at get set
it's all back
[Music]
all that attracted a different type of
young audience with the Saturday night
lifestyle sketch comedy
while also having a slightly older tone
it blew up internationally in countries
like the UK Australia and Canada getting
so popular that it ran for over 10 years
but all that wasn't all smiles behind
the scenes see all that was written and
produced by a ruthless man and this
ruthless TV Mogul would go on to
practically control Nickelodeon after
all that took off and that man was Dan
Schneider
look at a dance Snyder and Schneider and
we love you thank you so much dude Dan
Snyder was bestowed with the Lifetime
Achievement Award and some of the stars
from Drake and Josh Sam and Cat
Victorious and iCarly congratulated Dan
for making their careers
[Music]
did you say nice things about me because
I will tase her if necessary I have the
taser we haven't had to use it in a long
time I've said lots of nice things so I
said nice things today oh I'm kind of
scared I was a little scared
you give me you never get me I just did
oh my God
oh my gosh that scared me so
foreign
[Music]
who is Dan Schneider well if you've ever
watched a Nickelodeon show from 1995 to
2014 there's a good chance he created
the propaganda I mean TV shows that
helped mold your brain during your most
formative years Dan grew up in Memphis
Tennessee and by the age of seven he was
by far the heaviest kid in his class
terrified of being rejected by his peers
he decided that he was going to win them
over the only way he knew how by being
funny I wouldn't be thought of as the
fattest kid in class if they thought I
was the funniest kid in class he said
early on Dan knew that he wanted to get
involved in the TV business one day he
saw that a movie was holding casting
calls in Memphis and he gave it a shot
he landed a small part in a movie called
making the grade and was later casted in
a sitcom after getting noticed for the
role Dan was building up such a
reputation that he was invited to host
the second evercast choice award for
Nickelodeon that was his in the
opportunity that would forever change
his life Nickelodeon was looking for
writers to help create all laps and Dan
easily landed the gig after pilots and
from that point on it catapulted his
career with a network as a writer and
producer The Amanda Show Kenan and Kell
What I Like About You Drake and Josh Zoe
101 iCarly Victoria Sam and Katz the
more successful his shows got the more
powerful Nickelodeon became and thus the
more powerful Dan became soon Schneider
and the channel were so intertwined that
almost all of their shows were made by
him on the outside it looked like a
wholesome yet massively successful kids
TV network but on the inside Dan
Schneider and Nickelodeon were covering
up some deep dark secrets
adding on a Nickelodeon show was a dream
come true for most kids getting a huge
payday having fans being famous being a
child star but the people who actually
lived through it see that being a
Nickelodeon star is a lot less glamorous
than you would think my experience with
acting is I'm so ashamed of the parts
that I've done in the past I I resent my
career in a lot of ways I think like by
15 I was already embarrassed in her new
Memoir Jeanette writes about being quote
photographed in a bikini at a wardrobe
fitting and being encouraged to drink
alcohol by an intimidating figure she
simply calls the Creator in the excerpt
she wrote quote my shoulders do have a
lot of knots in them but I don't want
the Creator to be the one rubbing them
out I want to say something to tell him
to stop in her book she writes that
after Sam and Cat was canceled
Nickelodeon offered her a three hundred
thousand dollar thank you gift if she
agreed to never speak publicly about her
experience at the network whenever ever
had wardrobe fittings he always had to
be in them whatever the show was I
started to realize going like oh so the
Creator isn't in the room absolutely
loved Amanda Bynes growing up yesterday
it was reported that she had been placed
on a psychiatric hold after she was
found roaming the streets naked and
alone and then she told the driver she
was coming down from a psychotic episode
how much money did you make on a season
of Drake and Josh back then and
residuals no residuals no residuals on
kids TV I get residuals from Drake and
Josh I don't for a show that ran for 10
years all over the world like residuals
would have been nice you know and they
wouldn't let us negotiate for them the
show's doing well how about we negotiate
for some residuals they're like we'll
hire someone else no matter how good
their life Seen On TV off camera
Nickelodeon was ruthless to their young
actors both emotionally and financially
and Dan Schneider was at the core of
many of the allegations against the
network allegations started piling up
that painted the creator of
Nickelodeon's most popular shows in a
very very dark light Dan was apparently
a domineering cruel abusive dictator
that had complete control over the kids
who worked for him with just a few words
Dan can make or break a young actor's
career and he made sure to exercise his
power taking advantage of kiss and doing
things way too sick to talk about on
YouTube but because Dan Schneider was
Nickelodeon's Rainmaker Nickelodeon had
his back Jeanette McCurdy who played
salmon iCarly was offered three hundred
thousand dollars by Nickelodeon to keep
quiet about her experiences on the show
with Dan Schneider she turned down the
hush money and later spelled all the
secrets about her horrible time working
at Nickelodeon and who she calls the
Creator in her book most people agreed
the Creator that she references is Dan
as he created iCarly and Jeanette isn't
the only one who had a problem with
Nickelodeon and Dan Schneider another
girl that was on Zoe 101 said that Dan
verbally abused her onset so badly that
being on TV just wasn't worth it anymore
and she quits she was just 12 years old
at the time I see Dan Schneider come in
what now you know like I'm the problem
again we've already told you to stop
crying and we've already told you to
shut up and you're for hours and our
money in our time you know there were
reports that didn't constantly threw
Tantrums screamed and sent Furious text
to child actors on a show outside of
work hours after after it came out
addressing his creepy inappropriate
abusive behavior on sets where he had
all the control but it wasn't just
actors facing Dan's wrath he was
horrible to everyone that worked with
him virus complained that Dan blatantly
discriminated against women saying quote
he didn't like having female writers in
the writer's room and quotes even people
who didn't work with Dan Schneider found
Nickelodeon to be ruthless lead actors
said how the kiss Network refused to
give them residuals and threatened to
fire them if they dared to even ask kid
shows were always less like in between
in between Seasons we were like okay the
show's doing well let's renegotiate
these residuals they're like well harsh
we'll recast neb right now there are
thousands of kids across the country who
would want to do this yeah like they're
Savage Nickelodeon had all the leverage
and they knew it so they would squeeze
their child actors for all they've got
tossed them out continue making money
off of them for years to come and then
sign next kid in line to do the same
[Music]
when the nasty allegations about Dan hit
the media in full force Nickelodeon
publicly parted ways with him and
canceled all the shows Dan went into
Incognito he disappeared and tried
keeping a low profile that was until
2021 when Dan finally decided to address
all the accusations against him in an
interview with the New York Times Dan
insisted that his time off had nothing
to do with the laundry list of claims
against him but rather he was just
working on himself he said he even lost
100 pounds on the process he said that
it was said that social media pushed all
these lies about him that all the shows
were just about comedy and totally
innocence and he humbly summed it up as
whatever I do next I wanted to outdo
what I've done in the past and he's
right I mean come on doesn't this look
like a guy you would trust your kids
with as for Nickelodeon it looks like
they're doing their best to Rebrand
themselves and to erase any memory of
creepy Dan Schneider and is working
perfectly this year's Kids Choice Awards
Drew 3.1 million viewers a huge Spike
from last year's viewership it even
ranked as the top cable program among
kids Age 2 to 14 which means the next
generation of kids is falling right in
line when Nickelodeon's plans and even
though it looks like they've cleaned up
their acts we won't know what's actually
going on behind the scenes until the
kits are all grown up and the damage has
already been done
[Music]
foreign